mais voici maintenant l'invité d'essonne
dernière minute et s'est invitée c'est
marcel amont ou bonjour je vous
demandais vraiment ravi de vous recevoir
sur le plateau du 13 heures de france 2
pour la sortie d'un nouvel album
intitulé décalage horaire toute petite
question d'abord pour commencer pourquoi
si important pour vous de sortir un
nouveau disque alors que vous pourriez
aspirer j'allais dire à un peu de
tranquillité juste jouir du bonheur des
jours heureux
ce sont les jours heureux les voilà
c'est ça c'est cette surprise dans ce
métier rien n'est jamais gagné dans le
mien rien n'est jamais gagné et rien
n'est jamais perdu la preuve
ça fait 22 ans je n'ai pas enregistré de
disque et là je vis un conte de fées
n'exagérons pas mais qu'est ce que je
sais faire d'autre donc d'abord quel
effet d'ouvrir en commerces de
prêt-à-porter concert le chanteur quand
ils devaient bah oui voilà voilà la
réponse
et ça veut dire que ça ça vous apporte
aussi j'imagine beaucoup de bonheur à
vous le faites de ré enregistrer des
disques de retravailler avec d'autres
arrivent
oui avec ces jeunes gens qui sont là
nicolas richer ils sont venus me voir
parce que voilà henri salvador nous
avons ouvert une voie royale c'est ça
qui allez vous dire où il en rend compte
en écoutant le disque et oui par le
jardin d'hiver d'henri salvador là et on
dit tiens formidable tout est là c'est à
dire quand on s'est aperçu qu'en vingt
que tous les septuagénaires et plus
n'était pas grabataire et c'est une
vraie tout va bien et six jeunes gens se
sont mis en tête mon écoute puisque tu
as ruiné dans ta jeunesse que tu as un
peu laisser ça de côté
si on essayait sans décourager le public
quitte est fidèle depuis
deux décennies si on essayait de
rajeunir voilà ils ont dépoussiéré un
petit peu mon style est mon répertoire
sans braquer personnes non parce qu'on
n'a pas le sentiment non plus que c'est
vraiment contre ce que vous avez fait
avant simplement vous avez souhaité
travailler avec des gens de plus jeunes
générations
vous vous êtes avec agnès jaoui
notamment dans un titre avec gérard
darmon dans un autre avec didier
lockwood dans le premier il raffine ça
doit tuer votre fille et moi fils dont
j'ignorais que le chanteur nous fallait
être un vrai bonheur pour vous un vrai
bonheur un vrai bonheur
alors voilà il ya une chanson vous allez
nous chanter mais j'aimerais d'abord que
vous en disiez un vain mot c'est la
première de l'album
elle s'intitule démodé et on a vraiment
l'impression que c'est un sacré clin
d'oeil d'humour pour comment est bien
l'un de ces jeunes compositeur philip
lowe fredo m'amener une chanson et julie
de donner quelques idées il m'a dit tu
devrais mettre des paroles dit est ce
que monsieur est ce que je peux me
charrier un peu la vie vas-y et j'ai un
avis rajouter dans des bus si bien ce
que m'ont dit non non pas trop quand
même neuf ne te s'était pas créé tout à
fait crédible je pense attendit klein je
dis que je suis démodé dans le fond
démodé si j'ai continué à travailler
depuis 30 ans sans arrêter c'est parce
qu'il ya dans ce pays
quelques millions de personnes qui le
sont au moins autant que moi oui et puis
des jeunes qui vous écoute quand même on
va vous aider je vais vous demander de
rejoindre les y joue entre et nicolas
richard justement qui a réalisé un
disque
elle est en dropant les démolisseurs
suis pas d'enfant ordinaire j'ai trop
peur des courants d'air je suis tout le
temps aux antipodes des fluctuations de
la mode j'y peux rien en attendant c'est
comme ça puis pas de ça j'ai pas gros
j'ai pas le franchiseur - blue moi j'ai
besoin d'envoyer mais j y suis
des modèles j'adore jouer a dit wenger
j'suis made en soit je suis là rires ça
n'est pas gelé ricaner les rappeurs déjà
siécle un dernier jeu faisait fuir les
riches mais leur mère marché la danse je
me faisais un triomphe
moi j'aime le swing comme validé mais
j'suis pas qu'il y suis
les deux
merci à vous vraiment vous l'êtes pas
des manifestement top marcel amoussou le
redis décalage horaire qui vient de
sortir il ya quelques jours merci encore
c'est très agréable de vous recevoir sur
le plateau de france 2 c'est la fin de
ce journal
merci à vous de m'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo complète de nathalie
rihouet avec encore des alertes orange
notamment dans l'est puis tous une
histoire avec jean luc delarue 20h vous
avez rendez vous avec david pujadas
quant à nous on se retrouve demain même
lieu même heure